freude der sonne auf diesem kanal sind
wir freunde der sonne aber wir sind
keine freunde des klimawandels und
irgendwie wissen wir alle es geht so
nicht weiter wir müssen irgendetwas tun
aber wir wissen auch es ist nicht so
einfach
der verzicht auf fleisch und tierische
produkte ist gut für die umwelt aber
heute fragen wir uns wie gut wir
persönlich würde es zum beispiel schwer
fallen vegan zu leben und da ist die
frage berechtigt lohnt sich der aufwand
oder der verzichten wirklich können
hiermit veganismus die umwelt retten
oder sind andere maßnahmen viel
effizienter das klären wir jetzt pass
auf disclaimer vorweg ich werde jetzt
hier in diesem video die ethische fragen
also sollte man tiere überhaupt essen
bewusst ausklammern
nicht weil ich diese fragen nicht
wichtig finde sondern weil ich möchte
dass wir uns zumindest in diesem video
einmal ganz systematisch nur auf die
umwelt konzentrieren
das allein ist schon kompliziert genug
ihr werdet schon sehen deswegen auch tee
holen gemütlich machen ihr wisst
bescheid jetzt fangen wir an mit den
grundlegendsten grundlagen der ernährung
also das leben dreht sich um ein element
kohlenstoff alles leben basiert auf
kohlenstoff verbindungen in der luft
fliegt kohlenstoff in form von co2 jahre
pflanzen können das co2 aus der luft in
komplexere kohlenstoffhaltige moleküle
umwandeln zucker- stärke- fette wir
essen diese kohlenstoffhaltigen
verbindungen und wandeln sie um wir
nutzen die energie die beim umwandeln
dieser stoffe entsteht zum leben wir
wandeln sie außerdem in andere
kohlenstoffhaltige materie um also
gewebe muskeln hirnhaut ted und sie
atmen co2 wieder aus das können die
pflanzen dann wieder aufnehmen und so
schließt sich der kohlenstoff kreislauf
und ja ich habe hier schnittlauch
genommen um pflanzen zu demonstrieren
ist co2 aber auch ein treibhausgas und
das problem ist dass wir das schon lange
nicht mehr nur ausatmen sondern durch
industrie und co
sehr viel mehr davon freisitzen nur
haben wir nicht entsprechend mehr
pflanzen unser modernes
neben bringt also den
kohlenstoffkreislauf aus dem
gleichgewicht dankes bisschen genauer je
mehr pflanzen wir haben desto mehr co2 7
sie aus der atmosphäre und desto besser
ist es fürs klima ein wald bindet mehr
co2 als eine wiese und die wiederum mehr
als ein acker deswegen ist die frage
nach einer klimafreundlichen ernährung
auch immer verknüpft mit der frage der
weltweiten hunger bekämpfen
bis 2050 werden wir fast zehn milliarden
menschen auf diesem planeten sein also
die weltbevölkerung wird irgendwann
maximum erreichen und dann auch wieder
sinken aber so viele müssen wir auch
erst mal ernährten und wenn die
landwirtschaft so weitergeht wie bisher
dann geht das nur durch zusätzliche
ackerflächen und die sind hauptsächlich
dort wo heute wald ist deswegen ist es
gut fürs klima wenn wir ackerflächen
effizient nutzen also in der praxis
bringt auf effizienz maximierte
landwirtschaft natürlich auch andere
probleme aber für die grundlage ist
dieser zusammenhang trotzdem wichtig
also mit möglichst kleinen ackerfläche
möglichst viele menschen ernähren so wie
nutze ich ackerflächen jetzt möglichst
effizient ich kann auch diesen flächen
pflanzen anbauen und die an tiere
verfüttert also pflanzen in fleisch
umwandeln oder in milch doch diese
umwandlung ist ja nicht verlustfrei weil
das tier einen großteil der wertvollen
kohlenstoffhaltigen grundstoffe
verschwendet indem es sie in energie zum
leben umwandelt und den rest einfach
ausatmet preist also nochmal ich mache
das hier ganz bewusst so nüchtern dass
sich tiere hier nur als energielieferant
oder nahrungsquelle betrachte sie mir
das nach ich möchte nur dass wir diesen
ernährungs parteien mal logisch
nachvollziehen also effizienter wäre es
die pflanzen vom acker direkt selbst zu
essen denn mit jedem essen geht durchs
umwandeln energie verloren anders gesagt
die kriege mehr kalorien aus einer
ackerfläche wenn ich diese pflanzen
direkt selbst esse anstatt dass ich sie
an ein tier weiter verfügte und dann das
tier es und auch neben der ineffizienten
flächen nutzen
bringen fleisch und tierische produkte
noch andere umweltprobleme ein problem
ist dass tiere rülpsen und furzen und
zwar viel sonders kühe schafe und ziegen
denn in so einem wiederkäuer
verdauungssystem gibt es viele bakterien
die viele gase produzieren und darunter
auch methan ist als treibhausgas um ein
vielfaches schlimmer als co2 was machen
wir also wir holen uns mit den pflanzen
co2 aus der luft wandeln die um im tier
und das tier stößt dann ein viel
schlimmeres treibhausgas aus schlecht
für die klimabilanz und da hört die
geschichte ja auch noch nicht auf es
gibt noch mehr klimarelevanten
emissionen aus der fleischwirtschaft das
geht von treibstoff für die futter
transporte bis hin zu der energie für
verarbeitung und lager und all diese
sachen muss man berücksichtigen wenn man
den umwelt impact eines nahrungsmittels
bewerten möchte und genau das macht man
mit einem so genannten life cycle
assessment kurz lte auch umweltbilanz
genannt wenn man sich die lcs
verschiedener lebensmittel ansieht fällt
sofort auf das fleisch sehr schlecht
abschneidet besonders fleisch von
wiederkäuern
wegen des methan ausstoßen betrachtet
man die klimabilanz dann macht die
tierhaltung weltweit 14 5 prozent der
menschen gemachten
treibhausgasemissionen aus und das ist
ungefähr genauso viel wie innerhalb
derselben zeit aus den auspuffen aller
autos aller schiffe flugzeuge aller
transportmittel kommt wurde nur achte
das bedeutet trotzdem nicht das
tierische lebensmittel alleine genauso
viele klimagase verursachen wie der
gesamte transport sektor in dem fleisch
oder milch schauen wir uns lcs an also
ein recht umfassende betrachtung beim
transport nur die direkten emissionen
und zusätzliche emissionen die entstehen
durch die produktion der transportmittel
oder durch öl förderung für das benzin
das ist hier alles noch gar nicht drin
insgesamt verursacht der transportsektor
viel mehr treibhausgase als die tiere in
unserer ernährung da es also auch sehr
viel spielraum für eine verbesserung das
aber nur als einordnung den 14 5 prozent
sind natürlich trotzdem enorm viel jetzt
um das zu klären haben wir uns mit frank
von die frage zusammengeschlossen die
machen gerade eine ganze serie zum
klimawandel und beleuchten die in jede
woche von der anderen seite
frank habe mich auch zu hause besucht
aber dazu später mehr
wir haben uns jetzt konkret gefragt
heisst das jetzt nicht alles ganz
offensichtlich dass wir alle veganer
werden sollten könnten wir dadurch 14 5
prozent der treibhausgase reduzieren
damit wäre das klima nämlich geschmeidig
gerettet ganz so einfach ist das nicht
der euch wahrscheinlich schon gedacht
und zwar nicht nur weil einfach vegan
leben gar nicht so einfach ist sondern
weil diese zahl zwar nicht falsch ist
aber deutlich vielschichtiger als sie
scheint und auf diese schichten möchte
ich jetzt gerne eingehen in einer rubrik
die ich nenne erste sehen dinge mainz
die sache mit uns allesfresser
hier ist das ding will menschen sind
natürlich allesfresser aber tiere können
pflanzenteile essen die wir gar nicht
essen können zum beispiel messen will
nur die kölner
wenn wir jetzt den rest der maispflanze
ein tiere verfüttern und wir wiederum
die tiere essen dann kriegen wir aus
unserer ackerfläche mehr kalorien und
nutzen sie damit effizienter sehen
nummer zwei
die sache mit den böden dresden man
liest immer wieder dass über 70 prozent
der landwirtschaftlich genutzten flächen
weltweit für die produktion von fleisch
und milch verwendet werden diese aber
nur etwa 18 prozent der kalorien liefern
das klingt ja nach einer bodenlosen
verschwendung oder einer boden vollen
verschwendung
aber es gibt böden die man gar nicht
anders nutzen kann weil sie gar nicht
dazu geeignet sind um nahrungspflanzen
darauf an zu bauen
gras hingegen ist deutlich
anspruchsloser das wächst auch auf
schlechteren böden hier kann man dann
rinder und schafe weiden lassen
zwei drittel der flächen die für
fleisch- und milchproduktion verwendet
werden sind eben solches weideland das
für veganer weitgehend nutzlos ist
in sachen effiziente flächennutzung gilt
hier lieber tiere als gar keine nutzung
in ländern wie kenia oder der mongolei
ist ein großer teil der landwirtschaft
und damit auch ein großer teil der
ernährung der lokalen bevölkerung darauf
angewiesen diese böden zu beweisen
wenn diese menschen dort jetzt vegan
leben wollten dann müssten sie womöglich
wald abholzen um ackerflächen zu
schaffen die sie nutzen können oder sie
wären auf importe angewiesen weltweiter
veganismus wäre also gar nicht die
allerbeste lösung fürs klima gut jetzt
dem wir aber nicht in der mongolei oder
in kenia sondern in deutschland dass er
nicht gerade für seine weitläufigen
steppenlandschaften bekannt ist wie sehr
würden wir der umwelt helfen wenn wir
hier alle vegan leben würden für
deutschland gibt es leider noch keine
ausführlichen studien dafür aber für die
usa die er auch gute böden haben in den
usa entspricht der ausstoß aller
klimaschädlichen gase fast sieben
millionen tonnen co2 pro jahr
die landwirtschaft hat daran einen
anteil von ungefähr 9 prozent und fast
die hälfte dieser 9 prozent gehen auf
das konto hat doch wenn man die gesamte
tierhaltung abschaffen würde würde man
dadurch nicht die hälfte einsparen
sondern etwa nur ein drittel es liegt
zum beispiel daran dass es dann auch
keine gülle mehr gäbe zum düngen
man müsste dann energiereiche redinger
herstellen oder man müsste viele wiesen
in ackerfläche umwandeln und dadurch
würde co2 frei werden das vorher in der
wiese gespeichert war aber dass wieder
auch nur zur einordnung denn immerhin
nach diesen berechnungen ein drittel der
emissionen kann man sparen und man
kriegt ja auch noch aus denselben
ackerflächen mehr kalorien raus zur
ernährung der bevölkerung fing nummer
drei die sache mit der gesunden
ernährung hier ist das ding wenn wir aus
dieser sehr komplexen gleichung rund um
klimawandel und ernährt jetzt einfach
nur die tiere raus nehmen sonst aber gar
nichts ändern
dann bleiben wir erst mal mit einem
riesen batzen futtergetreide zurück da
sind zwar genug kalorien für uns alle
drin
aber das ist natürlich keine ausgewogene
ernährung wir müssen stattdessen mehr
obst und gemüse anbauen und obst und
gemüse sind im schnitt anspruchsvoller
und brauchen mehr ressourcen als
getreide sind also damit auch weniger
klimafreundlich anschaulich wurde das in
dieser amerikanischen studie wo
ausgerechnet wurde was passiert wenn
alle amerikaner sich einfach an die
offiziellen ernährungsempfehlungen des
landes halten würden zunächst wären in
den usa prinzipiell weniger kalorien
empfohlen als im durchschnitt gegessen
wird wenn alleine diese kalorien
empfehlung eingehalten werden würde
damit alle langfristig normalgewichtig
wären würde das bereits die emissionen
um neun prozent einsparen dann gibt es
natürlich noch die qualitativen
empfehlungen also weniger bürger und
donuts und mehr obst und gemüse und auch
milchprodukte so wird es zumindest
empfohlen und jetzt kommt ein sehr
interessantes ergebnis würden sich alle
amerikaner an die offiziellen
ernährungsempfehlungen halten dann
würden trotz kalorienreduktion die
emissionen zunächst steigen und zwar
nach diesen berechnungen um satte 6
prozent das liegt zum einen an den
vielen empfohlenen milchprodukte und für
die natürlich auch kühe gehalten und
gefüttert werden müssen aber auch an der
starken zunahme von obst und gemüse wenn
wir uns die lcs verschiedener
gemüsesorten ansehen dann fällt auf dass
manche gemüsesorten relativ viele
emissionen verursachen natürlich nicht
im vergleich zu fleisch aber im
vergleich zu kartoffeln oder getreide
dazu gehören zum beispiel auch ocado
auberginen oder blattsalat und auch die
aspekte regionalität und saisonalität
fließen natürlich auch in die
klimabilanz mit 1 uhr um zum beispiel
salat wurden sind in der saison sie mich
lieber freundlich
außerhalb der saison wenn sie in
beheizten gewächshäusern produziert
werden verzehnfachen sich die emissionen
und bringen die gurke auf dasselbe klima
level wie frischkäse oder spargel lokal
im sommer kein problem
nur frisch aus peru oder mexiko
eingeflogen führt das zu einer zwölf bis
dreizehnfache
emission und macht den spargel zucker
belastender als schweinefleisch erste
maine singh würden wir in deutschland
alle veganer werden würde einen teil der
eingesparten klima emissionen an anderer
stelle entstehen aber unterm strich geht
die rechnung auf weniger tierische
nahrungsmittel führen insgesamt zu
deutlich weniger klima emissionen
das problem verschärft sich eigentlich
nur ja ob denn gerade die ökonomisch
aufstrebenden länder deren fleisch
konsum steigt und er wird auch noch
weiter steigen
für viele gehört fleisch zudem
erreichten wohlstand dazu und ich denke
nicht dass wir die meisten leute davon
abbringen können wie bei allen
nachhaltigkeitsfragen wird es auch hier
nicht diese eine einfach umsetzbare
super lösung geben stattdessen müssen
wir gleichzeitig möglichst viele
lösungswege verfolgen zum beispiel durch
futter forschung dieser kalorien verlust
von der 20 nahrung zum fleisch der wurde
in den letzten jahrzehnten immer weniger
das liegt unter anderem an überlegten
futtermischungen die effiziente verdaut
werden
und auch die methan bildung kann durch
geschicktes futter reduziert werden
deswegen wird weltweit an immer besseren
futtermischungen und zusätzen geforscht
und für jeden von uns persönlich gilt
nur wenn ich es jetzt zum beispiel nicht
schaffe komplett vegan zu leben oder
komplett vegetarisch dann muss das ja
nicht heißen und dann halt nicht zum
beispiel fand eine britische studie
heraus dass gemäßigte fleischesser die
weniger als 50 gramm fleisch pro tag
aßen im gegensatz zu starken
fleischessern die mehr als 100 gramm
fleisch pro tag aßen insgesamt 900
kilogramm co2 emissionen in einem jahr
sparten das entspricht immerhin ungefähr
einen hin und rückflug nach new york und
auf eine ähnliche größenordnung kamen
auch schwedische wissenschaftler die
ausrechnen was wohl passieren würde wenn
alle menschen im land die hälfte des
fleisches aus ihrem essen ersetzen
würden durch proteinreiche hülsenfrüchte
wie bohnen erbsen und außerdem wenn wir
schon tiere essen dann können wir das
auch effizienter machen indem wir
möglichst viel von dem tier verwerten
und nicht nur diejenigen brust oder das
rinderfilet ist und generell weniger
verschwinden wenn wir mehr essen kaufen
als wir am ende essen dann ist das
direkte ressourcen verschwenden und
unabhängig vom fleisch kann man wie
gesagt auch versuchen sich möglichst
regional und saisonal so nähren was
natürlich auch ein verzicht bedeutet zum
beispiel auf die avocados mexiko oder
auf währenden winter also wenn es um
ernährung und klima geht dann läuft
jeder positive beitrag auf irgendeine
art von verzicht hinaus die frage ist
auch was könnt ihr am ehesten sich also
was könnt ihr am besten beitrag wenn ihr
euch vegan regional und saisonal ernährt
super und wenn ihr einfach nur den
fleischkonsum um die hälfte reduziert
hauptsache er tut was ihr könnt wenn ihr
dafür ein bisschen inspiration braucht
und wenn euch noch andere aspekte des
klimawandels interessieren dann ist die
unbedingt bei meinem kollegen frank von
die frage vorbeischauen wenn ihr wollt
und breit der einzige der über den
wörther fahrrad für 123 den palast ihm
ein taxi matschies die haben nämlich
momentan und die nächsten wochen eine
ganze serie zum klimawandel deswegen
hallo freunde der sonne ich bin frank
von die frage und auf meinem kanal gehe
ich aktuell der frage nach was kann ich
gegen den klimawandel tun wenn ihr das
sehen wollt dann klickt doch mal da